the hill has this uh startling headline
startling for them anyway High School
boys are trending conservative
oh no dear God
a popular narrative suggests young
people are reading out from the article
are liberal and getting more liberal
thus social media buzz when a chat
surface in Spring that seems to suggest
12th grade boys have become
overwhelmingly conservative as with many
Reddit posts and viral tweets the Tweet
was more complicated the truth was more
complicated but the numbers do say this
12th grade boys are nearly twice as
likely to identify as conservative
versus liberal according to a respected
Federal survey of American Youth
an annual survey is over the last three
years roughly one quarter of high school
seniors self-identified as conservative
or very conservative on the monitoring
the future survey a scholarly Endeavor
that dates to the 1970s only 13 percent
of boys identified as liberal or very
liberal in those years the figures
represent a striking shift in the
political views of boys as recently as
the late 2000s
liberal boys occasionally outnumbered
conservatives back in the Carter era
both boys and girls lean liberal
nowadays it's girls who are drifting to
the left the share of 12th grade girls
who identified as liberal Rose from 19
of 2012 to 30 in 2022. only 12 percent
of girls identify as conservative in the
last year's survey administered by the
University of Michigan
uh young women too are trending liberal
women ages 18 to 29 or more likely to
identify as liberal now than at any time
in the past two decades according to
Gallup surveys young women are also
almost twice as likely as young men to
claim the liberal tag a widening gender
gap in political beliefs so that's kind
of the headline
um that you've got
uh overall
young men and boys are trending
conservative and when you when you
narrow it down to 12th grade boys there
are twice as likely to identify as
conservative versus liberal
which is a striking difference from the
past as they point out now
I think there are a few things happening
here a few reasons why teenage boys and
young men are increasingly becoming
conservative
and the first is that conservatism is
rebellious okay it's edgy it's uh
offensive in our culture by our culture
standards it's the rebellious edgy
offensive thing
and if you have that kind of renegade
Instinct that desire to Rebel as many
young people do especially boys
uh then this is where you go
as I pointed out before if you're a kid
in high school and you want to be edgy
and cool you can't do that by adopting
the same position as your middle-aged
math teacher
like the moment that your math teacher
starts waving a pride flag and talking
about how the Bible is evil is the
moment that it becomes extremely uncool
to love the pride flag and hate the
Bible
uh this drives towards uh you know
there's a drive among the youth
obviously towards Rebellion that's not
news to anybody
and historically it's been harnessed by
the left against the right and that's
the reason why if you go back as they
point out you go back to the 60s and 70s
you're going to find that the situation
is completely reversed where young boys
are much more likely to identify as
liberal versus conservative that's
because that was the rebellious thing at
the time
uh for a long time you know what we
consider now to be conservative
ideals
were the popular mainstream ideals the
conservative position as we consider it
now was the dominant cultural position
which is not the case anymore
which means the left is in control it
means they're the dominant cultural
Force which is bad but the good thing is
that they lose their Rebel status that's
the one good thing even if they even if
they pretend to still have it which they
do
so you end up with like um
aging punk rockers still going out and
pretending to Rage Against the Machine
by saying everything that your HR rep at
work would say
but it's all a charade and and kids for
the most part see right through it
um
so this is a great Advantage for us
that that we should be harnessing much
more than we are and you have to harness
it in a Smart Way obviously I mean you
can't actually go up to kids and say hey
kids want to be edgy and cool be
conservative
you can't say it as uh you know in in a
way as on the nose as that because that
makes it sound lame but that is
basically the message and the truth
conservatism is edgy
it's much cooler
um and partly because it's the only
place where you can have a sense of
humor
um and that's the other thing about
teenage boys and I know this from having
been one not that long ago well pretty
long I mean really long ago but still I
was one at one time and
I can still remember that as a teenage
boy you have a very outrageous offensive
kind of morbid uh aggressive sense of
humor teenage boys amused themselves by
insulting each other like among friends
just insulting each other in extremely
vulgar and personal ways
um and to some extent you never grow out
of that yeah even as you become a man as
men we never quite grow out of that we
still we still think it's funny to like
make fun of each other and stuff but
there's no room for for that on the left
at all I mean you you cannot have a
man's sense of humor on the left you
just can't profiling surveillance and
data harvesting are just a few things I
don't like about tech Giants but what
can you actually do about it when you
rely on so many of their products well
the good news is it doesn't take much
for you to take a stand for less than
seven dollars per month you can join me
and fight back against big Tech by using
expressvpn big tech companies make their
money by tracking your searches video
history everything you click on and then
selling your personal data expressvpn
helps you anonymize much of your online
presence by hiding your IP address a
unique identifier that every device has
that allows big Tech to match your
activity back to you that's why I use
expressvpn on all my devices to make it
much more difficult for them to exploit
my data for their own profits best part
is how easy it is to use the expressvpn
app I just tap one button on my phone or
computer turn it on and that's it your
data is your business visit expressvp
n.com walls right now to get three extra
months free that's expressvpn.com Walsh
to get protected now
expressvpn.com Welsh
Innovation refunds has been helping
small businesses that qualify to get a
business payroll tax refund through the
employee retention credit act or also
known as the ERC the ERC is a tax refund
for businesses that kept employees on
payroll for parts of 2020 and 2021 if
you own a business with more than five
employees you you could have money
waiting to be claimed right now you just
have to know how to claim it that's
where Innovation refunds comes in
Innovation refunds is dedicated helping
business owners navigate the process and
their independent tax attorneys can help
your business
stay compliant with IRS guidelines and
regulations Innovation refunds does not
provide tax or legal advice they work
with an independent network of tax
professionals and they will share
information with them to evaluate and
process your claims go to getrefunds.com
to determine eligibility if you qualify
you could be on your way to receiving
money for your business there's no
upfront charge since they don't get paid
unless you get paid so go to
getrefunds.com or dial 1-843 refunds
that's getrefunds.com or 1843 refunds
terms and conditions apply in fact as it
turns out you can't have a man's sense
of anything on the left you cannot be a
man on the left
which brings us to the second factor
which could explain why boys are
increasingly becoming conservative which
is that the left
if you are a high school boy the leftist
is doing nothing but keeping scorn and
contempt on you
um telling you to be ashamed of yourself
of your masculinity calling you toxic
lecturing you scolding you yelling at
you
on and on and on a constant never-ending
harangue
another difference between between now
and back then in 60s and 70s it used to
be that when you thought of the um
the humorless scolds what immediately
comes to mind is like the church lady
right the conservative you're thinking
of conservatives it's supposed to be
these humorless skulls don't have a
sense of humor they're offended by
everything uh writing angry letters
because they're offended by this and
that
that is now that's the left that's what
the left does
that's their gig
uh and they're they're very excited to
explain to you why everything you think
and say is offense offensive especially
if you're a male
um
so what else are good if you're a
teenage boy what else are you gonna do
so you've got these people over here who
hate you and don't even disguise their
contempt
and meanwhile they're they're do on the
other end of it they're doing nothing
but heaping praise and adulation and
celebration for like every other group
they're constantly say oh you're so
special you're great you're wonderful
you should be accepted exactly as you
are everything about you is perfect
you're the the most wonderful thing on
the planet that's their message to
everyone but then they turn around to
you say oh you scumbags
one should be more like them
except you can't be more like them
because that'd be appropriation
uh and I think teenage boys hear that
and they respond exactly as you'd expect
them to
which means that again on the right uh
the goal here is to is to
harness this
um
to our advantage and ultimately the
advantage of the culture and Truth
because the really the really good thing
is that uh in this case it's not just
that
going over to the right is now
rebellious and edging all the rest of it
it's but that's also where the truth is
on all these issues
uh when we see these what I what I find
to be extremely encouraging videos of um
again High School boys you know tearing
down the pride flags and mocking
attempts by schools to you know groom
them into the LGBT cult these videos
come out very encouraging
um but it's not just because it's it's
it's political politically advantageous
for us it's because what they they are
rejecting falsehood in favor of the
truth
and
the question is how are we going to
harness that
on the right there hasn't been nearly
enough of that
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts